[موسيقى]
إنه أمر غريب
لأنني لم أكن عداءًا قبل أن أكون مبتورًا ، اعتقدت أن
العدائين مجنونون ، بدأ زوجي في
الركض وكان نوعًا ما يدخل في الالتراس
والأشياء ، لذلك كنت
مفتونًا بالرياضة ، لذا اعتقدت أنك تعرف
ما سأقوم بتجربته ، يمكنك الدخول
في تلك اللحظة في الجري حيث تكون
فجأة مثل آه هذا ما يدور
حوله وأنت نوع من الوقوع في حبه
[موسيقى]
عندما أصبحت مبتورًا ، إنه مثلك
أصبحت محدودة للغاية كما يخبرك الجميع
أنه لا يمكنك القيام بذلك ، لا يمكنك فعل ذلك
، وبعد ذلك عندما أضع شفرة تشغيل
، شعرت وكأنني كنت أطير كنت
أفعل شيئًا اعتقدت أنني
لا أستطيع فعله وهو  نوعًا ما يضع الحياة
في منظور أكثر قليلاً
ويمنحك هذا الإحساس بالقليل من الحرية
[موسيقى
] قضيت أيامًا جيدة وأيامًا سيئة
لم تكن تعرف أبدًا ما سيجلبه اليوم في بعض
الأيام وكأنك تعرف ماذا
عليك فقط أن تنجزها وتمتصها
تمامًا مثل قدم واحدة أمام
الأخرى وفقط  اذهب وبعد ذلك في أيام أخرى
ستشعر بالرضا وكأنك تطير ، من
الغريب كيف يعمل الجسد والعقل ،
لكنني وجدت أن هذا ربما كان حوالي 90
عقليًا مقابل جسديًا ، لقد شاركت في سباق الماراثون
رقم 50 وعقلي قال أنك تعرف
ما هو جيد 50 هو مسافة جيدة ،
فقط استقال من هنا ويبدو الأمر كما لو
أنك شاركت في 50 ماراثونًا في 50 يومًا ، إنه
لأمر مدهش أن عقلي فقط هو الذي تم
القيام به وكان الأمر كما لو أنني اضطررت
لمحاربة تلك المشاعر لنوع من
تجاوز الأمر وقل فقط أنك تعرف ما
الذي لا يزال بإمكانك فعله
[موسيقى]
كان لدي هدف صغير حقًا لأنني
كنت مثل ، أنت تعرف ما سأكون سعيدًا
بعشرة آلاف ، يمكننا على الأقل مساعدة
مبتور واحد وأنا  تم تفجيره بعيدًا لأننا
جمعنا 194 ألف دولار ،
لذلك كان أمرًا لا يصدق
[موسيقى]
واثقًا من أنني أتمنى أن أكون قد بدأت في الركض في
وقت مبكر جدًا عندما أصبحت مبتورًا
لأنه من وجهة نظر عقلية
ساعدني بالتأكيد على قبول
من كنت لذلك أريد فقط  المزيد من مبتوري
الأطراف لمحاولة الركض لمجرد ذلك
أعتقد أنه يساعد فقط
من وجهة نظر عقلية ، لقد علمني نوعًا
ما أنني قادر على القيام بأكثر من ذلك بكثير
وأعتقد حقًا أننا إذا
دفعنانا للخروج قليلاً ، فاجأنا أنفسنا نوعًا ما
[موسيقى]
أنت